Digamos que se nos dice que 0 = x² + 6x + 3,
¿qué valor de x satisface esta ecuación? Pausa
el video e intenta resolverlo. Muy bien, ahora
trabajemos juntos. Lo primero que trataré de
hacer es ver si puedo factorizar esta expresión
del lado derecho, esta expresión es igual a 0,
si pudiera factorizarla podría ayudarme a
resolver esto. Entonces veamos: ¿puedo pensar
en dos números que cuando los sumo obtengo 6 y
cuando los multiplico obtengo 3 positivo? Bueno,
si estoy pensando sólo en términos de enteros,
3 es un número primo, sólo tiene dos factores,
1 y 3; y veamos 1 + 3 no es igual a 6, por lo que
no parece que factorizar me vaya a ayudar mucho.
Entonces lo siguiente que haré es completar
el cuadrado, de hecho si hay valores de x que
satisfacen esta ecuación, completar el cuadrado
nos ayudará a resolverlo. Y para hacerlo diré
que 0 es igual a -permíteme reescribir la primera
parte- x² + 6x y luego escribiré el + 3 aquí. Mi
objetivo es agregar algo a la derecha, justo aquí,
y luego restaré lo mismo, así que realmente no voy
a cambiar el valor del lado derecho, quiero
agregar algo aquí que luego restaré para que
lo que tengo entre paréntesis se convierta en un
cuadrado perfecto. Bueno, la forma de convertirlo
en un cuadrado perfecto, y hemos hablado de
esto en otros videos, cuando presentamos la
idea de completar el cuadrado, es que veremos este
coeficiente de primer grado aquí, este 6 positivo,
y diremos, bien, la mitad de eso es 3 positivo,
y si lo elevamos al cuadrado obtendríamos 9,
así que sumemos un 9 aquí, y luego también vamos
a restar un 9. Ten en cuenta que no hemos cambiado
el valor de la expresión del lado derecho,
estamos sumando 9 y restando 9, de hecho los
paréntesis están ahí para ayudarnos a que esto sea
un poco más claro visualmente, pero ni siquiera
necesitas los paréntesis, esencialmente obtendrías
el mismo resultado. Pero entonces, ¿qué sucede si
simplificamos esto un poco? Bueno, lo que acabo
de mostrarte -permíteme hacerlo en este color-,
esta parte puede reescribirse como x + 3², es
por eso que agregamos 9 allí. Dijimos "Muy bien,
intentemos probar con un 3 porque 3 es la mitad
de 6", y si elevamos 3 al cuadrado obtenemos un 9,
y luego esta segunda parte justo aquí, 3 - 9 =
6 negativo, entonces podríamos escribirlo así:
0 = (x + 3)² - 6. Y ahora lo que podemos hacer es
aislar esta (x + 3)² sumando 6 en ambos lados,
así que hagamos eso, agreguemos 6 allí,
agreguemos 6 allí, y en el lado izquierdo
obtenemos 6 es igual a, en el lado derecho sólo
queda (x + 3)², y ahora podríamos sacar la raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados y podríamos decir que la
raíz cuadrada positiva o negativa de 6 es igual a
x + 3. Y si esto no tiene sentido, sólo pausa
un momento el video y piensa en ello: si digo
que algo cuadrado es igual a 6 eso significa que
ese algo será la raíz cuadrada positiva de 6 o la
raíz cuadrada negativa de 6. Y, ahora, si queremos
resolver para x, podemos restar 3 de ambos lados,
así que restemos 3 de ambos y ¿qué obtenemos?
Del lado derecho nos queda una x y eso será
igual a 3 negativo ± √6. Y ya hemos terminado;
obviamente podríamos reescribir esto y decir
x podría ser igual a 3 negativo más √6, o
x podría ser igual a 3 negativo menos √6.